After provisioning your
beacon, turning it on,
setting the power
level et cetera,
it's time to set it up with
data by registering, attaching
data, and managing the beacons
with the Proximity Beacon API.
Hi, I'm Marc Wandschneider and
I'm a software engineer here
at Google and I will run you
through all the necessary steps
to do the above.
Not too long ago, we released
details of our new beacon
platform based on the
Eddystone open standard
and the Nearby Messages API.
Nearby Messages is a new
API that enables your device
to react to nearby objects
and micro-locations,
such as bus stops,
train platforms,
or even indoor locations
such as exhibits in a museum.
It makes use of a whole host of
technologies including Wi-Fi,
Bluetooth, ultrasound, and most
interestingly for us right now,
Bluetooth beacons
powered by Eddystone.
We have some other
videos talking
about beacons in general,
and using beacons
with Nearby Messages.
But let's take a seconds to go
over our basic scenario again.
First, you need to
get some beacons.
This is usually done by talking
to one of the beacon vendors
out there selling beacons
compliant with the Eddystone
open format.
They'll provide the
hardware and the software
needed to provision or
activate these beacons.
You use the Nearby Messages
API on your mobile device,
such as your Android
or iOS gadget
to listen for messages when
one of these beacons is seen,
and to return attached
data for them.
Like for example, that this
beacon is meant to be at bus
stop ABC.
Now, it's that attached
to data that we're
going to be taking a closer
look at in this video.
Just how exactly do I
associate data with my beacons?
Well, this is done using the
Proximity Beacon API, Indeed,
in addition to
that, this API lets
me manage my entire
fleet of beacon hardware,
register sightings,
and possibly even get
some diagnostic information
about the beacons.
The Proximity Beacon
API was designed
to make deploying
and managing beacons
easy with three key pieces
of functionality in mind.
Beacon administration,
beacon sighting and serving,
and beacon diagnostics.
The largest and most important
of these bits of functionality
is the portion relating to
managing your fleet of beacons.
It's this corner of
the API that you'll
use to first register your
beacons when you get them,
and then to control their
lifecycle, including
their eventual retirement
or decommissioning.
The beacon life cycle
is roughly as follows.
First, you take your
unregistered beacon
and register it.
Once registered, your
beacon can switch
between active and
inactive states.
Registered beacons
that are active
will return information when
you query the citing and serving
APIs.
Thus, when I see beacon
one, two, three, four, five,
and it is active, when you ask
for more information about it,
the Proximity Beacon API
will tell you about it.
Inactive beacons,
on the other hand,
are registered and can still
be modified in our system,
but don't serve.
When an app asks if that
beacon has any data associated
with it, the Proximity Beacon
API will just say, nope.
Let's say you've taken
a beacon out of service,
or maybe it gets lost and
want to make sure it's never
accidentally reactivated.
Decommissioning deactivates
the beacon permanently.
This can never be
undone, and the beacon
will never serve again.
Nobody can ever register
this beacon again,
and if you want to use the
physical beacon hardware again,
you're going to need to use the
Hardware Vendors Provisioning
app to give it a new beacon ID.
Once a beacon is registered
and in the system,
we need to associate some
attachment data with it
in the cloud.
These form the content
of the messages
that the Nearby Messages API
present to your applications
at run time.
For this, we have ways to
create, fetch, and delete
attachments with our beacons.
You can put a decent
amount of data
in there-- JSON, XML, BLOBs,
really whatever you want.
But, stuffing massive JPG
images into the database
isn't going to work.
You've got 1k to work
with for each attachment.
So for larger objects,
maybe splitting it up
into smaller chunks, or perhaps
a link to the ultimate resource
will be the way to go.
And that's basically what the
Management API is all about.
There are a few other
methods for fetching things,
but it's pretty simple stuff.
You register beacons, add
some attachment data to them,
and you're ready to go
with Nearby Messages.
Next, we have the Serving APIs.
For those of you who will
be using Nearby Messages
you won't need to
worry about this.
Nearby does all of this for you.
However, for those who want to
build complete beacon solutions
on your own, there's
a cool method here
you want to know about.
Get info for observe beacons.
That's a mouthful.
Or just get for observed in
the rest version of the API.
Basically, and
this is what Nearby
is doing for you under the
covers, when you see a beacon,
you query this method to see if
it's a beacon you know about.
If it is, then you
get information
for the beacon and attachment
data for it as well.
If it's not a beacon
for which there
is available registered
data you can use,
the API just returns
a blank response.
Finally, if you've
got a large fleet,
or they're deployed
remotely, we've
got yet another end-point that
will make your life easier--
the Diagnostics API.
And extremely important
part of managing
a large fleet of beacons is
getting information on them,
including battery life,
and whether the beacon
is likely to be where
it's supposed to be.
The Diagnostics API will
help you with all of that.
A really great way to see how to
use the Proximity Beacon API is
to check out the sample
applications we've put here,
at github.com/google/beacon
platform.
There's one for Android
and one for iOS,
and these are fantastic ways
to see how to use these APIs.
You can use these
samples to get familiar
with the basic flows of
registering and setting up
attachment data for beacons.
You can also use these samples
as a basis for your deployment
application, and integrate it
with your work flows and data.
There's a ton of information
available for working
with Eddystone beacons, Nearby
Messages, and the Google
Proximity Beacon API.
First, check out the docs
for the Proximity Beacon
at developers.googl
e.com/beacon/proximity.
Or just visit
developers.google.com/beacons
for more on the broader picture.
As we mentioned before,
our API samples are
at github.com/google/beacon
platform.
And you can also learn
more about Eddystone itself
at github.com/google/eddystone.
We've also made a
couple of other videos
on beacons, which of
course, are great viewing.
So with this knowledge
combined with what
I talked about in the using
Nearby with beacons video,
you've now got a complete
story on how to use beacons
with Nearby Messages.
I hope you find it as exciting
and interesting as we do.
We can't wait to see
all the cool new stuff
you're going to come up
with this technology.
[MUSIC PLAYING]